bom dia a todos
pela hora já é bom dia já não é volante
então não vai falar sobre ganha vai
falar sobre marketing digital antes mas
eu queria agradecer o convite da
organização é um prazer estar aqui com
vocês
o desafio foi lançado foi falar um crime
sobre o futuro do marketing digital e
falar sobre o futuro de uma coisa que
não existe é complicada e
invariavelmente o marketing digital não
existe o que existe é marketing aplicado
aos canais digitais
então o que nós temos que entender a
primeira coisa que temos que entender é
que efetivamente o mundo mudou a forma
como nós comunicamos a forma como nós
levamos usa para eles no nosso dia a via
ea forma como nós socialmente nos ruas
dynamos mudou
isto vocês vêem aqui era impensável há
dez anos atrás
ok principalmente pela parte do
presidente dos estados unidos e do papa
os outros possivelmente seriam
aceitáveis
os outros dois modelos efetivamente não
eram juntamente com esta mudança é uma
coisa que nós chamamos de mim não é
nenhum fio que é o segmento tirado mais
jovem que tem um comportamento
completamente diferente do nosso
entender isso é fundamental para
entender o marketing digital ea forma
como nós nos comunicamos ao espaço muito
mais tempo online gostam muito mais do
conteúdo autêntico e eu estou muito mais
influenciados por que os outros
produtores fazem do que por aquilo que
as marcas fazem
e esta mudança de paradigma trouxe uns
também uma mudança no campo dos negócios
a uva é a maior empresa de táxis do
mundo e não tem um único táxi web é a
maior empresa privada do mundo e não tem
um único até um golo de babá foi
considerado o tenista mais valiosas do
mundo e não tem uma única peça em troca
os caipira é maior empresa de
telecomunicações do mundo e não tem
sequer em infraestrutura de
telecomunicações e temos mais
o que é a maior plataforma de conteúdo e
mídia do mundo e não produziu uma única
peça do conteúdo netflix é a maior
empresa de transmissão de filmes e
séries e não tem uma única sala de
cinema
a apple e google são as maiores
distribuidoras de software do mundo e
não produzem software algum software
elas produzem mas em grande medida o
software que elas distribuem não é
produzido por elas e afectos que a maior
lista de moda do mundo e que tem certo
aqui no porto
a unicer portuguesa não tem também uma
única peça em estoque no marketing
há uma coisa que nós chamamos de
auto-bomba martin e em bom marketing ao
tema marketing é tudo aquilo que nós
podemos fazer fora que têm impacto
dentro como por exemplo rádio televisão
magazin
os milênios os mais novos que hoje estão
interagir com o marketing principalmente
o marketing digital 84% de deus não
confiam na publicidade tradicional ou
seja se vocês fizerem um anúncio na
televisão um anúncio em uma revista e os
letra ao menos tentam se apegar
mas eu confio muito no embalão martin
que é uma coisa interessante
aos 44 por cento de 2009 também é
confiar em ex partes mesmo não se
conheçam nossa jesus confiam mais em uma
pesquisa que fazem no youtube e
encontrou um vídeo de uma pessoa que
eles nunca viram na vida e confiam mais
na alma do que não se gosta fazendo a
magazin ou na televisão e isso muda
muito a forma como nós lidamos com o
marketing ea forma como nós comunicamos
ao longo destas análises para entender o
que seria o futuro do marketing digital
ou que o que de alguma forma poderíamos
considerar o futuro é chegar à conclusão
ao longo dos últimos anos que aquilo que
é mais importante para as empresas hoje
são os dados
os dados são efetivamente o novo
petróleo para as marcas entender os
dados e trabalhar os dados é fundamental
para entender os padrões e as pessoas
são altamente previsível
todos nós somos extremamente previsível
vamos fazer uma pergunta quem é que já
descansou um ebook que nunca leu o banco
do brasil
boa retaguarda
todos nós fazemos isso e todos nós
continuamos a fazer isso
finalmente guardamos os erros naquela
pasta zinha em que dizemos sim eu um dia
vou ler isto certeza absoluta em
uberlândia tendência se formos analisar
os últimos cinco anos no google pra
entender como é que as pessoas pesquisam
do pai natal é óbvio quando é que as
pessoas pesquisam pelo pai natal o que
não deixa de ser triste porque as
pessoas só pensa no pai natal under
metal
é triste mas efetivamente nós somos
muito previsíveis na forma como
pesquisamos na forma como interagimos na
forma como lidamos com as marcas
depois trouxemos uma coisa muito
interessante eu tenho não tem raízes no
brasil mas considera o brasil uma
segunda casa trabalho muito com o brasil
e próximo algumas tendências de pesquisa
que fazem muitos no brasil e está no
brasil as pessoas pesquisam muito por
exemplo por um milagre e na elite que é
uma coisa extraordinária
não basta ser um milagre tem que ser em
neve é diferente mas pesquisando por
outras coisas interessantes como por
exemplo passar a mão é pecado porque
depois temos a parte religiosa muito
forte e é preciso entender que passar a
mão pode ser complicado mas não fica
porque porque no brasil faz todo sentido
pesquisar sobre como fugir da idéia
efetivamente fácil mas a melhor de todas
não é essa
como é que alguém para pensar como é que
os ex avaí quando é que terminam
bullying para quando estou no banheiro é
sério com alguém pensa nisto
sim os brasileiros pensam e pesquisam
que é uma coisa interessante
infelizmente os nossos compatriotas não
gostou muito
juntamente com os dados nas uma coisa
que não sei se alguém ouvir falar sobre
os prédios novos aos modelos preditivos
que é que o que as marcas estão utilizar
hoje ainda não é utilizado com
freqüência com que provável - vai ser
utilizado no futuro e sim e sim quer a
gente queira quer não
nós hoje vivemos num grande gurada ok e
as marcas sabem isso as marcas discutam
as marcas vêm as marcas sabem tudo o que
vocês fazem
vamos mostrar um primeiro caso
como é que vocês sentiriam se uma loja
soubesse vocês neste caso das senhoras
que alguma de vocês estaria grávida
antes mesmo antes mesmo de vocês saberem
que estão grávidas
foi precisamente isso que aconteceu nos
estados unidos em 2014 e vamos contar
essa história de ficar sem essa história
maravilhosa a target que uma loja nos
estados unidos criou uma coisa que é o
prega-se score vai de zero você saiba o
que eles fizeram foi um olhar para os
dados e para os tipos de produtos que as
mulheres geralmente consomem e depois
foram funilândia esses dados e
perceberam que as mulheres que ou estão
em fase de gravidez ou estão em fase de
pré gravidez
geralmente tinha um comportamento de
compra numa faixa de até 25 produtos e
aos quinto llugar aos 25 produto e com
base neste fím produto e nas combinações
de compras chegaram ão predictions core
um prédio nas escolas vai de 0 mais
sangue eo que elas faziam e fazem ainda
hoje se uma mulher que tiver um prédio
nas escolas superior a 80% seus começam
a disparar cupões para comprar fraldas e
para comprar produtos relacionados com a
gravidez faz todo o sentido
e foi precisamente isso que aconteceu em
2014 uma jovem ainda no secundário um
dia foi a target e quando chegou a casa
com sorvete cupons para comprar fraldas
e para comprar produtos para bete que
pessoas que não foi simpático preocupa e
revela percebeu a situação e foi à loja
reclamar com a loja
o que vocês estão a fazer propostas
estão a incitar a minha filha
engravidara vocês estão malucos daqui
vez e passou se na loja em loja tentou
explicar o que se passava e tanto
explicou que o senhor chegou a casa e
percebeu que tinham atividades físicas
em casa que eu desconhecia
resumo da história uma semana depois
tanto eu como a filha descobriram que
ela estava grávida está em análise de
dados é entender o comportamento humano
entender o que são os padrões para todos
nós temos padrões eo mais engraçado é
vocês pensarem que o facebook com 48
horas de antecedência consegue prever o
início ou fim de um acirramento entre
duas pessoas
mesmo antes delas saberem disso
esperados
isso acontece todos os dias ali hajj o
facebook até consegue mais eu vou falar
mais à frente sobre isso está o estudo
relativo à análise preditiva do facebook
a love story e este estudo tem a ver
precisamente com a forma como as pessoas
se relacionam entre elas e não só o
facebook por exemplo caso vocês não
saibam consegue prover com apenas 18
antes se uma pessoa é gay ou não parece
mas não é aquilo que você normalmente
gostam ou não gostam numa rede social
diz muito sobre quem vocês são e é só
olhar para os padrões são todos à rádio
é só entre portar os dados e tentar
perceber o que é que efetivamente os
dados nos dizem porque obviamente todos
nós de alguma forma temos quadrante o
twitter por exemplo consegue prever um
surto de gripe em até seis semanas antes
do surto se iniciar mais uma vez
análises de idade
é tudo uma questão dos padrões e
entender os padrões e obviamente é
quando nós paramos um caminho para
pensar que é o google fábio por um de
nós andamos que o facebook sabe o que é
que nós fazemos com 500 nós falamos
o twitter sabe o que é que nós
comunicamos e quem é que nossos clientes
e todas as grandes empresas armas onde
sabe o que é que nós compramos é e
passava o que nós ouvimos e todas essas
grandes empresas têm basicamente toda a
nossa informação todo nosso de a via é a
única coisa
que elas não fazem supostamente é ouvir
os nossos microfones mas eu também não
acredito nisso é você inventar uma
história muito rápida a pouco há poucos
dias estive com um grande amigo meu e eu
estávamos a contar uma história muito
engraçada e depois nesse dia eu vou
porque acabaram por acontecer duas
histórias o primeiro modelo depois uma
outra que aconteceu exatamente no mesmo
dia
então a história dela era muito simples
não estava no hotel saiu do hotel e em
conversa com um amigo disse que o
chuveiro do hotel estava com baixa
pressão e logo a seguir ao tirar a mão
do bolso
abr o facebook e leva como a campanha de
chuva
não há coincidências e como não há
coincidências
azar dos azares no mesmo dia estava a
dar um curso com esse meu colega é um
lisboa ainda a nossa turma estava o piso
cá e eu estava no horário da moça falar
com um colega sobre a panair sobre a
marca para janeiro e assim que tirar o
fone abril o facebook aparece uma
campanha da paineira e/ou jurou a pés
juntos que eu não via uma campanha de
apanha no facebook a mesma obra ou
facebook com dois microfones ou facebook
ok para mim é e após esta análise é eu
fui tentar entender o que é que
efetivamente as marcas qual é que a
tendência das marcas nós nós ganhamos
muito a nossa comunicação nas redes
sociais
olhamos para o marketing digital é de
uma forma muito superficial máquina
digital não é redes sociais e chama-se
chão mídia ao show media marketing
o marketing digital vai um quilinho ao
índice e o que as marcas estão a fazer é
fazer hoje é trabalhar o big data
provavelmente muitos de vocês já ouviram
falar em gata visada é essencialmente
dados em informação o vosso
comportamento nas redes sociais
o vosso comportamento no gps do google o
vosso comportamento na pesquisa o google
consegue prever também se uma mulher
está grávida uma semana antes só com
base nas pesquisas que ela faixa
são padrões são da rádio e toda essa
informação estados la
do lado das marcas as marcas analisando
essa informação e procurando por padrões
encontram facilmente padrões para
perceber se um homem é ganhar não é aí
se uma mulher está grávida não está
grávida
se porventura uma mulher está doente ou
não está doente um homem e é fácil
provar isso
é só analisar os dados a universidade
cambridge lançou não há muito tempo uma
aplicação que vocês podem estar saltou
por alguma razão ela volta com a
intenção que chama médicos só se faz
para pesquisar a e que basicamente se
vocês podem fazer um modelo preditivo do
vosso perfil é basicamente vocês fazem
login com o facebook ou o twitter e com
base no vosso comportamento nas redes
sociais
e aqui vocês gostam ou não gostam eu vai
vos dar o vosso museu positivo enquanto
pessoas nomeadamente se vocês tão grande
ou não são 10
se vocês têm mais tendência para ser
criativos ou não se vocês têm mais jeito
para as matemáticas ou não e diversos
outros prefixos é essencialmente a
mensagem que eu queria deixar é
marketing digital não é redes sociais é
marketing digital é um marketing
aplicado aos canais digitais
as redes sociais são um desses canais
mas que é que vocês fazem na internet
efetivamente fica na internet e as
marcas sabem isso e isso não é
necessariamente uma coisa má
é eu falava agora no intervalo
precisamente sobre isso isso não
necessariamente uma coisa má por fax
vias marcas entenderem os nossos padrões
e conseguirem personalizar o marketing
ao ponto de falar mas o ano
nós entregamos uma mensagem totalmente
personalizável uma pessoa é e essa
mensagem tem muito mais impacto e é
muito mais interessantes dos nós
tivermos a preparar pra toda a gente da
mesma forma sem qualquer tipo de
sinalização
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]